hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to M tomorrow what is
supposedly a very scary and very well
made and very difficult horror game
that's a point-and-click style adventure
now this is made by a new developer
who's new to the scene so we don't know
what's going to come out of this game
but apparently people are saying that
it's very very good and since I'm so
good at games I'm not gonna have any
trouble with this at all please stop
laughing I haven't gotten to the game
yet warning this game has content which
many can find offensive and/or
disturbing great also this game is very
hardened unforgiving excellent so don't
be surprised to have trouble solving the
riddles okay so it's not just gonna be
me there's not flappy bird or casual
genocide in order to finish it you will
need to think outside of the box I'm
great
I got tiny box Tim right here I don't
want to go into the box because out
don't get you say rules at the game as
they constantly change great bend and
twist douchery inbound think of it as
the dark souls of adventure games you
will fail over and over kit used to it
it's fine everything you will experience
is exactly as planned and remember there
is always a solution grade you woke up
in a dungeon it smells like death you
hear distant sounds of scratching and
it's heading your way what do you do oh
something's heading my way run the other
direction look around
oh are you okay I'm dead my name is
William apparently alright then you're
welcome into dungeon 2 uh-huh so this is
how this game's gonna be wait you wait a
bit the sound is coming closer hmm oh
wait longer wait again it's almost here
what was that got you some okay
shut up I'm doing something oh it's my
mom okay if you just said my name was
William why is this game proving here
okay fine I get it yeah run the other
direction very smart thing to do
as you run down the corridor you find
yourself in a metal fall you can hear
something running behind you if you
won't ask fast it'll reach you go right
oh you haven't locked doors behind you
you're dead Danny what does that even
mean it didn't have an option to do that
okay run the other direction as you run
down the corner you fool what oh ah it's
beard to be a door switch would you pull
quickly oh I'm getting the hang of it
okay if you're a strong bump and loud
inhuman screams I actually don't but I'm
gonna let that go just because I'm
assuming that you couldn't record
inhuman screams you in her Hall way
there are dozens of doors on both sides
of corridor at the end you see a wall of
water Oh
observe the liquid wall is still far
away the corridor is silent if you're
only your own breathing or do hi there
anything in the environment that I need
to click so this is what you mean step
forward you move deeper into the hallway
as you step all the doors burst into
violent knocking and bumping you feel
endangered okay I definitely hear that
but I thought all that number Jeff bored
you move deeper in the hallway okay okay
all right my name is Robert now okay so
that didn't go terribly well run the
other way lock the door like that pull
the switch you're strong bomb okay so go
right but I don't know if there's
anything here I just want to observe it
and then go back go go back can't doors
let go forward hey reality around you
bends and twists you find yourself in
the middle of what the hell is this what
the hell are you guys there's a path
leading forward but someone is anyway
he's wearing an odd mask it's not a mask
well which is it you're not really being
very clear okay so I don't have any
other option but going forward so I
click on the mask a mask
hello don't go there please you can't
you will be hurt I won't let you go I
love you so much you are everything
- I have punch him punch him in the
gonad you punch him in the mask face he
takes the punch his eyes bleed you feel
a sudden rush of satisfaction you want
more I'm gonna kick him I'm gonna kick
him - good
oh you kick him in the stomach and he
bends in pain but quickly recovered to
his initial stance blood is pouring down
from underneath the mask it feels so
good oh wow you slice his throat he
chokes and gags odors and blood yet
remains standing in your way just die
already
oh man I didn't want it to end up like
this his neck snaps like a dry branch he
died he's still standing even after
death
but he is an obstacle no more ecstasy
overwhelms your mind holy crap well I
guess I can go forward now you come to
the crossroad there's something in the
dark you could hear it moving beside the
bushes and trees okay you follow the
path you encounter a child standing in
the middle of the road it's your son
he's crying his eyelids are sold with
barbed wire what does that even happen
rescue him as he moved toward the runic
barrier flash glory barbed wire speed
from your son's eyes quickly with all
the barbed Oh can't force yourself to
cross the barrier you're helpless
worthless what a pitiful excuse for a
father
why is this happening all right bye then
oh hey well okay oh hey boy you don't
over there through the bushes and trees
you come across the small cottages the
presents is walking around the house and
cheering no one will pass hello you seem
normal take a step forward and the
creature instantly blinks right in front
of you inches away from your face it
does interact but all its eyes stare at
you feels uneasy sending you'll find
yourself in a weird voice I am pride
bound for you me kneel and beg
forgiveness speak you're discussing
maggot describe what a wretched pool of
vomit you are I am stupid that's
probably what I do I'm stupid that's
just me though I'm really really dumb
like really dumb of course you are
you're brainless mindless bag of meat
bones I'm the best you didn't you're a
disgrace
you earned your life no future of course
yeah and a bright one you'll live doing
pointless things and you'll die leaving
behind nothing but rotting meat and
bones
you'll die on mist unnoticed huh what
can you repeat that I'm weak and
miserable did you what did you say say
it louder I can't hear you
that's the spirit ready to die go down
we are an L silly well at your own
personal private hell go down go down go
help help whatever then I grant you
death you are now free from me for a
time broken and bleeding crawling at the
bottom now you have the chance to rise
beyond see you soon okay so I started
from the middle now I'm at the bottom
but then I get to go to the top started
from the bottom I get to go to the top
gonna happen Oh fine I'll just die then
what pride won't pay your bills won't
feed your kids won't make you abandon
your pride okay on the other direction
knock at the door
hi that was it I thought so that is
creepy though I just had to go into the
house when the guy was moving to the
left and right tap dancing lessons
the interiors a mess there's moss on the
walls most of the furniture is rotten oh
and an old lady walking back and forth
you can smell the metallic scent of
blood from her great it's bleedy grandma
okay what am I supposed to do about tap
dancing bloody grandma outside okay okay
all right cool that was that was great
I'm glad that happened so what the hell
am I supposed to do now there's gotta be
something here it's gotta be some hair
it's gotta be there's gotta be like a
secret thingy a secret little doodad I
will share some secrets with you I need
at least ten okay so well I mean one
pass probably has more than 100 got to
maggot teeth great I've always wanted
these what they have just one time -
what happens if I get more what happens
if I just get all the maggot teeth in
the world
ha ha they're getting a little faster
now oh this is supposed to be a
challenge now all right I got 21 teeth
how about them apples you can pass
safely through a silent corridor great
the silent corridor always what I wanted
okay so oh the silent corridor that's a
silent core ah I know I know
the journey is the answer oh so she'll
give me clues the more teeth I give er
okay so let me just get another set of
ten and then maybe maybe just maybe
maybe there's gonna be another clue
that's gonna be vital to my survival in
this scenario grandma grandma grandma
I got a present 40 years for Moses okay
that doesn't help me at all Graham thank
you very much okay so the silent
corridor I should be able to pass
through now Bonnie the man's still there
but if I go right
and I see a wall water and this place is
silent board doors but now I should be
able to go forward who Deva ah yes oh
but it's not too bad this is a bunch of
baloney this is Ark I'll be right back
su nombre by Bonilla Leggio Mel Runa
skipped Norma new man ji don't think no
I'm the Tooth Fairy you shut up and let
me alone alright lady show me your teeth
40 years ya have cancer you're going to
die great thanks
that's some coordinates someone look up
those coordinates for latitude and
longitude and see what that leads to
because I'm curious okay
fire will not harm the messenger of
water thanks grandma
need to lose your pride to free yourself
from its power Rima grandma I got more
teeth somehow takes a while to fill an
angel lust yeah what would you know
about an Angels lust anyway did you have
some prior experience with some lusty
angels these maggots this is not a game
I thought it was a gaming youtuber is
[ __ ] is wrong
oh oh I get it now okay this took me way
too long and I like I had to pull up the
walkthrough just to see the clue as to
what I was supposed to go here and the
clue was so simple grandma was right and
grandma was right damn it grandma
I should have written down all her clues
the silent corridor what I didn't notice
is that this happened the floor I went
through this once and one step forward
and I died but I need to I need it
that's what the patience thing was all
about I need to let them there we go
patience young padawan now right you're
under water at the bottom of surprise
you discover that you can breathe water
is strangely thick like fresh jelly oh
boy fresh jelly it also has a very foul
taste great
should I swim up should I look for
anything down here the beach is covered
with dead bodies also great you just you
notice none of them have a face just
numbers burned within their skin where
the face was supposed to be your clothes
are dripping wet okay what about three
three oh one but I need an active good
to be able to get him Bobby oh hello an
archangel stands by the water I've
killed them all so I could go to heaven
I can take you with me if you want you
know I like it down here in the bizarro
world where everything isn't what it
seems to be the jungle oh hey there's a
friendly snake hello kind sir would you
like to pet me absolutely not
Oh what am I supposed to do now it's
gonna game me over and then I'm gonna
die and then I'm not gonna have anything
available to me I don't even know if I
was supposed to go to Grandma's house
alright so I probably shouldn't all
right fine I'll pet ya know maybe I
won't pet yeah
ah that feels great you know what you're
so kind wish our snake God would be like
you Oh
pineapples Rhea pineapples raining from
snake heaven Thank You snake god I guess
suddenly pineapples alright well that
that turned out better than expected oh
go to wall of water tall wall rises in
front of you it has a gap which you can
use to get to the other side but there's
a weird fire burning which boxer what I
don't want to walk through the fire
I just got pineapples you think I want
us waste it all on fire although roasted
fine apples I've heard it's very good so
somehow I need to walk through the fire
in the plains
vegetabies and very dense here yes I
know all these fruits and vegetables
raining from the heavens
hello cancer now I petted you once I
don't want to pet again I've already up
the pineapples so one of water go back
but I don't want to go back to sea yet
this guy's still here should I talk with
this guy I mean I guess I'm a lazy but
violence and pain motivate me if you
want me to flap my wings and fly you
need to hurt me don't worry I enjoy it I
don't think I want to do
[Laughter]
this is not going anywhere ah
[Laughter]
this is a waste of my time but
achievement hooray okay so numbers were
burning in the skin is there any way
that I could find like number three 301
because that was a number that was
mentioned before so if I could find
three 301 it would be advantageous to
mine so if I walk through the fire I'm
probably gonna die it's my guess take a
step into the fire and you start burning
you take off your burning clothes but
the fire is glued to your body you die
people okay [ __ ] you this is some
[ __ ]
hey still raining pineapples for some
reason I guess I don't need to pet the
snake again so this might be a clue my
clothes are dripping wet right now
that could be a clue maybe I should be
able to walk through the fire if my
clothes are dripping wet if I'm really
fast about it
the jungle go deeper into the jungle
walk good fire oh my wet clothes somehow
extinguish the magical fire that burned
me alive that doesn't make any sense our
kids are walking the park of course
assuming the floor is lava I'm a misfit
you okay crossroad two three pass flow
i'm dead young human coming in here in
plain sight in plain sight eh well
aren't whoa hey oh okay so I got a
dancing Jesus what does that even mean
is he giving me the finger hey how dare
you Jesus that's not very nice so okay I
don't I don't get what you're trying to
say dancing Jesus if if you could get
buddy Jesus over here and tell me that
what I'm supposed to do I don't well you
know what I'm not even gonna question
that anymore because frankly I don't
give a damn I don't know they'll just
happen but hey we're here still alive I
think I should go the desert wind blows
pushing endless amounts of sand through
the world young God's mercy okay so
what's in the swamp swamp smells fecal
and sulfur and the stench almost makes
you vomit and you have this weird
feeling back your head like someone's
watching you
Oh is someone is it back Satan those are
bad sounds you see you snake being a
powerful aura of lust and desire
surrounds her right hello handsome let's
play a game you'll give me my name and
I'll give you his name okay goodbye
well I mean are you the snake god that
the other snake was talking about or
what okay so desert sand everything sand
you've been traveling for one year
indoors easy there you know what sand
every the two
years ago man I'm a little tired only
three years okay five years well okay is
it just looping through and years DS oh
man this is a long time to be traveling
[Music]
what is this place
who are you can i select something
please
you've won await our arrival oh now I
can select something okay
we are three three the grandma talk to
me about this grandma was telling me
this crazy story about three three oh
one by an act of God to change something
land rust and moss his domain hidden
under thin skin of reality no one comes
in no one gets out the name is the key
but there's no heel okay so can you tell
me the snake gods name cuz I need that
name so I can get his name three 301 I
hope this assistant doesn't end in a
game over cuz out really suck
whoa
hey cool 40 years Oh enough okay you
find yourself on the outskirts of
Houston ancient skyscraper our towering
above horizon go to City something awful
a veneer you can smell rotting meat but
no bodies are to be found the city's
silent you can feel strong tension in
the air something is bound to happen
wait 40 years you think someone would be
patient enough to wait for me those
sewers of the hospital what is left for
dead
hospitals ruinous ponds the movement and
the one of the windows upper floor found
near bias and black ooze at the bottom
this place gives you the cream Oh
probably shouldn't inspect to use but
whatever Lube is pitch black tar their
hairs floating in the service oh this is
gonna be like grudge good thing I'm in
the hospital again because I lo look at
the worms why am i why do I want to look
at worms
those are not words they're cut off
fingers there dozen of them all wiggling
and moving Oh lovely what good
decoration for this lovely place in our
small room with three doors labeled
seventy-nine and three you can sense
someone is standing on the other side of
each door waiting a strong sensation of
danger fills this place look around
inspect the room notice that the writing
is this isn't a game this is real
hey that's what grandma says this isn't
a game okay okay seventeen nine and
three what am I supposed to get out of
this I mean that's the only door that's
not the same as the other ones I'm
betting if I pick the wrong one they're
gonna kill me so I'm assuming I don't
have enough information information Wow
why is there a mouth of the end of that
that's so gross I don't want to jump
into the mouth why would I jump into the
mouth alright let's jump into the mouth
underwater oh great
how did that happen how in the world did
that happen
okay so 1700 hey Hebrew Hebrew Hebrew
Hebrew Hebrew Hebrew Hebrew okay so oh
oh I see it okay there's a little shadow
oh there he is
oh man that was really really cleverly
hidden huh I had no idea oh okay gotcha
gotcha gotcha gotcha
Eber Bieber Bieber paper her album is
that good okay so did I do it Heber he
oh that's the name that's the name Heber
your name is Heber oh cool
good Heber laughed but I lied I
forgotten his name we all did because he
did
maybe cicada we'll know tell them I've
sent you you can find them in heaven
[Applause]
okay hey Bruce and may he burrows a liar
she forces others to keep her promises a
scallion is the name but the name lost
his owner find him make him remember
door number six cross no other works oh
wow okay hey who are you you enter a
void of white flames in light there's
the giant beings standing before you
fire shrouds him entirely yet he suffers
no harm II gaze at something above his
arms open are you God being speak with
passion his voice is gentle and warm
Barkley what's good in him and I am
dying say my name your name is God's
eyes up and wider a shy spark of hope
glitters inside it feels like time is
stoped and every particle live exist
until it's it's breath
reading okay her I guess I'm waiting to
so everybody's just wait patiently
okay I had to look this up I had an idea
of what I was supposed to do because
it's waiting I didn't actually say the
name yet but I forgot what the name is
the name is apparently this scallion you
were waiting oh do I need prison this is
this is this is what is this what is
this
tell me what this is thank you thank you
so very much B aku as this is not a game
eyeballs oh crap that was quite an
adventure okay absurdly complex because
I've the end I forgot the name I should
have written things down like I forgot
that some things in this game like you
need to write things down but there was
a lot of this game that was like a red
herring I wasn't even supposed to go
like grandma's house it was only if I
needed the clues and in all honesty I
didn't really need all that many clues
except be patient and the silent hallway
like that is it selfless it's a clue I
thought it was an unlocking because I
got that first but oh that was really
cool that was like really really cool
for a point-and-click flash game I think
that was really really interesting
because obviously I had a tough time
with it took me a long time to be like
45 minutes to be what should have been
like a 15 minute game and there was a
lot of backtracking back and forth but
it was fun to explore it was fun to see
all the pieces of the environment
because there were some there were some
things that were not good and there was
some things that were very good I'm not
not good in his it was a bad game but
there were some things that were
[ __ ] in terms of oh god you killed
me with that that's such [ __ ] but
that was this part of the game and it
was actually interesting kept me engaged
like it kept me engaged through the
whole thing but if I didn't have to walk
through obviously I don't think I would
have been able to solve the hallway
puzzle or that last one without writing
down the name I would had to go back or
whatever but either way this is great
game this is this guy's first game that
he made I think it's phenomenal I would
love for a sequel to this game because
this was just bizarre interesting and
fantastic so we get away thank you so
much the developer for making this game
if you want to play this game for
yourself or check out the developer give
them some good words of encouragement
check the link in the description below
and check out the description for any
other cool crazy games like point click
stuff that I played in the past play a
lot so thank you everybody for a much
for watching and as always see you
[Music]